[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE ENDAHL: So quick
background on Fleetsmith,
we automate device setup,
intelligence, patching,
and security for your
company's Apple devices.
One of the coolest
things we do is make it
so that factory fresh laptops
and iPhones and iPads can
be drop-shipped directly
to remote employees
without prior
manual setup by IT.
And as soon as they're
unboxed and connect to Wi-Fi,
they automatically enroll.
All the apps and settings
are installed automatically
over the internet, securely.
We built our product
on GCP, in part,
due to Google's high
bar for security.
And we actually roll our
own Kubernetes cluster
on top of GCE and use
Hashicorp Vault for secrets
management, PKI, and
crypto as a service.
If we were actually going
to deploy Kubernetes today,
we would use GKE.
We're only rolling
our own cluster
for some legacy reasons.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Awesome
JESSE ENDAHL: So
this talk assumes
that you have some knowledge
of containers and Kubernetes
and focuses on
practically protecting
your workloads in GKE.
Specifically,
we're going to dive
into what's your
responsibility vs. what
Google handles for you.
I will say also, just in
general, security in the cloud
is that shared responsibility
between your cloud
provider and you.
Google does a lot of things
to protect the underlying
infrastructure, like
encryption at rest by default,
and also providing
capabilities to you
that you can use to protect
your workloads, like I am.
As newer infrastructure
models emerge,
it's not always easy to figure
out what you're actually
on the hook for.
So that's really what we're
diving into on this talk.
So let's jump in and review
some Kubernetes basics,
from a security point of view,
to make sure that we're all
on the same page.
So within a Kubernetes
cluster, there's only really
three core, fundamental pieces.
These are the parts of the
diagram that you see in
dark gray, and let's
walk through them
from the bottom up.
So at the bottom layer,
you've got the storage.
That's etcd.
Think of this like the
Kubernetes hard drive.
Next up, you've
got the master that
controls your entire cluster.
And then the next layer
up, you've got the nodes.
That's the virtual machines
that are running your pods,
and pods are just collections
of one or more containers.
So let's now walk
through the damage
that can be done at each
layer, from the top down.
So the top layer, you've got the
containers, again, in the pod.
If an attacker can
control a container,
they can do things
like abuse compute
to do things like mine
cryptocurrency, for example,
schedule arbitrary
workloads on the node.
If they're able to
escape the container,
potentially access
customer data.
And if there isn't a strong
security boundary there,
they could potentially
escape to the node.
From the node, if an
attacker can control a node,
that means they can control
all the pods running on a node.
They can do things like abuse
compute at the node layer,
kill existing workloads,
and run arbitrary workloads.
They also may try to attack
the master, the next layer up,
and do things like denial of
service attacks, for example.
So next up, you've
got the master itself.
That controls your
entire cluster.
It controls workloads, where
they're scheduled, everything.
So if an attacker compromises
your master, that's pretty bad.
They can completely take
your environment offline.
And short of killing
the entire cluster,
there's really not
much you're going
to be able to do to be able to
react to that type of attack.
Finally, etcd.
Again, like you're
Kubernetes hard drive,
that stores the
entire cluster state.
So it's kind of like
stealing a hard drive.
They're going to get
all your configs.
The attacker could
create, modify, or destroy
your entire cluster,
and they may even
be able to recreate or model
your entire cluster elsewhere.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So let's
look at Google's shared
responsibility model and how
that applies to Google Cloud.
So you might have heard this
term, shared responsibility
model, before.
It refers to how, in the cloud,
the cloud provider and the user
split the responsibility to
protect what you're running.
So to be successful at
this, your cloud provider
has to be really clear about
which aspects of security
they're responsible for and
you're responsible for.
Generally, providers are
responsible for securing
infrastructure, and you're
workloads.
Let's break this down
for Google Cloud.
So as you can see
in the diagram here,
Google Cloud manages
the blue bits,
whereas the user
manages the green bits.
For infrastructure as
a service, on the left,
users are responsible for
things like network security,
the deployment itself, and web
app security, whereas Google
is responsible for just
the core infrastructure.
For platform as a
service, in the middle,
Google takes on more
of the responsibility,
including components like
authentication, identity,
and operating the service.
The user is still responsible
for deploying and securing
their application.
And on the right, for
software as a service,
Google is also responsible
for these pieces.
And so you, as the user, are
only responsible for protecting
your data and content using the
appropriate access policies.
This breakdown is actually
available in a white paper
that we published late last
year on incident response,
and I'll link to that
at the end of the talk.
But looking at this,
where does GKE fall?
It's probably closest
to the middle.
That is Google manages
a lot of the day
to day running of the
service, but you're still
responsible for your specific
workloads that run on GKE.
So let's quickly recap
what actually happens
at that bottom layer,
first-- the blue that
goes across all of the bottom--
and how Google protects
those services on Google Cloud.
So one of the key
security differentiators
for Google Cloud is our
core infrastructure.
The infrastructure doesn't
rely on any single technology
to make it secure.
Rather, we build security
through progressive layers
that deliver defense in depth.
So starting from the
bottom up with hardware,
Google purpose builds
hardware in our data centers,
from chip to network, in order
to ensure a secure supply
chain.
Service deployment.
We have a build, test,
and deployment pipeline
that ensures that code running
on our servers and our data
centers is meant to be there,
so that any application
binary that runs
the infrastructure
is purposely deployed.
This lets us
enforce requirements
like ensuring that
code is reviewed
by a second reviewer and other
such policies and requirements
we might have.
Once deployed, we don't assume
any trust between services.
They actually need to
authenticate to each other
in the environment.
So we built this
infrastructure to be
multi-tenant from the get go.
At the storage layer, data
storage and infrastructure
is automatically
encrypted at rest
and distributed for
availability and reliability.
We also limited strict
data access controls
and robust logging features
at the storage layer,
underlying several
of the applications
that you can use
on Google Cloud.
Identity and access.
All identities,
users, and services
are strongly authenticated.
This authentication
for users, for example,
using hardware second
factor, helps protect
against phishing attacks.
Secure communication.
Communications over the
internet to our cloud services
are encrypted, and
communications between services
internally are
authenticated and encrypted
when they go between
physical boundaries.
And operational and
device security.
The scale of our
infrastructure allows
us to absorb a lot of attacks,
including DDoS attacks.
And our ops team
works 24/7 to respond
to threats and incidents.
All of this is
explained in detail
in another white paper called
our "Infrastructure, Security,
Design White Paper,"
that I'll also
link to at the end of the talk.
But just note that
the way that Google
approaches a lot of
these things is unique.
Anything that runs
on top of this stack,
including Google's workloads,
but also Google Cloud
workloads that our users want
to run, benefit from having
these underlying protections.
So going to GKE, beyond
that base infrastructure,
let's look at Kubernetes.
If you're running Kubernetes
yourself, for example, on GCE,
on prem, whatever
it happens to be,
you're responsible for
managing all of it, including
the control plane and day
to day operational work.
We often see users start
with their own deployment,
and then when it becomes
too much to handle,
migrate over to GKE.
If instead, you use
GKE, Kubernetes engine
does a lot of the
heavy lifting for you.
So for Kubernetes
Engine, at a high level,
the items on the left, Google
is responsible for protecting,
in addition to the
underlying infrastructure
that I mentioned already,
the Kubernetes distribution.
So Kubernetes Engine
makes available
the latest upstream
version of Kubernetes,
supporting several
minor versions.
Providing updates to these
is Google's responsibility.
The control plane.
In Kubernetes Engine,
Google manages
the control plane, which
includes the master
VMs, the API server, and
other components running
on those VMs, and
the etcd database.
This includes upgrades, again,
including patching, scaling,
and repairs all
backed by an SLO.
The operating systems
that your nodes run,
such as Container Optimized
OS, or COS, and Ubuntu--
Kubernetes Engine promptly makes
any patches to these images
available.
Note that this is the system
running on your nodes,
not the OS running
inside your containers.
Think about containers
having two OSes
when you think about this.
And the last piece
that Google manages
for you are Google Cloud
integrations for IAM,
cloud audit logging, cloud
security command center, Cloud
KMS, Stackdriver, et cetera.
These enable controls available
for IS workloads across Google
Cloud directly in GKE.
Conversely, the user is
responsible for protecting
the pieces on the right, the
nodes that run your workloads,
including VM images and
your configurations.
You're responsible for any
extra software installed
in the nodes or any
configuration changes made
to the default. You're also
responsible for keeping
your nodes updated.
Google provides hardened VM
images and configurations
by default, manages
the containers
that are necessary to
run GKE, and provides
patches for your OS.
You're just responsible
for upgrading.
If you use node auto upgrade,
it moves that responsibility
of upgrading the
nodes back to Google.
And you're responsible for
your workloads, including
your application
code, Dockerfiles,
container images, content,
and your running containers
and pods.
This includes leveraging GKE
features and other GCP features
to help protect what you're
running in containers.
So let's go through a
couple of the components
here, the control plane,
the worker nodes, and then
your workloads, to see how
we would protect each piece.
So the control plane, first.
Google, I just mentioned,
is responsible for securing
the control plane, which is a
component of Kubernetes that
manages how Kubernetes
communicates with the cluster
and applies the user's
desired state to the cluster.
This is Google's responsibility.
What does that mean?
Well, if you look at how
GKE's architected, in GKE,
the hosted control
plane components
run in a Google
owned GCP project.
And they control resources that
are in a user's GCP project.
Each customer's control
plane components
run on GCE instances, and these
instances are single tenants,
meaning that each
instance runs the control
plane and its components
for only one customer.
So what's actually in
that control plane?
A couple of different pieces.
First, the master VM.
It's a set of virtual machines
that runs master components.
Like I just mentioned, these
are single tenant GCE VMs
in a Google owned project.
Google uses Container
Optimized OS, or COS, for these
and manages the health of these
VMs, including updating the OS.
The API server, scheduler,
controller manager,
and other controllers run
on top of these master VMs.
These are the typical functions
of your Kubernetes cluster.
After all, the API that you're
interacting with when use GKE
is the same as a
normal Kubernetes API
that you get by
running it yourself.
It just happens to
be managed by Google.
The control plane
also manages etcd,
which is the database
behind Kubernetes which
maintains state.
Just like the rest of GCP,
content stored in etcd and GKE
is encrypted at the file
system layer by default.
So you don't have to do
anything to get that.
Etcd only listens
on two TCP ports,
one to communicate
with the Kubernetes
API and the other for server
to server communication.
When transmitting traffic from
one entity server to another,
these communications are
protected using mutual TLS.
Next piece, the control plane
also runs the cluster CA
and manages the cluster's
root of trust key material.
Each cluster has its own
root certificate authority.
The API server and kubelets rely
on Kubernetes cluster root CA
for trust.
Each cluster runs its own CA, so
that if one cluster's CA would
be compromised, no other
cluster's CA would be affected.
An internal Google service
manages route keys for the CA,
and these are privately held by
Google outside of the cluster.
IAM authentication
and authorization
is handled by the
master, as well.
This works the same way for
the Kubernetes API server
and etcd, as it's done for
other Google Cloud Services.
And lastly, the master includes
the audit logging configuration
for the master components.
This provides a detailed record,
available in Stackdriver,
of calls that are made to
the Kubernetes API server.
That was quite a lot.
So the goal here and throughout
Kubernetes Engine, as you'll
see, is to give you strong
security everywhere, control
where you need it, and
sane defaults in case
you never quite get
around to configuring
that thing yourself.
So keeping the goal of
sane defaults in mind,
we've been making
hardening changes
to the control plane over time.
So let's see what's
actually changed, recently.
Let's look at the change in
some of the recent GKE releases.
First, in 1.7, the
Kubernetes dashboard in GKE
had its highly privileged
admin access removed.
You might have heard of a couple
of public hacks of Kubernetes,
in which case,
you've probably seen
the dashboard
prominently featured.
Tesla, Aviva, Weight
Watchers were all
affected in late
2017 and early 2018,
where they had their dashboards
deployed on the public web,
not password protected, and
had privileged cloud service
account credentials in there.
Attackers found the dashboards,
went in, took the credentials,
logged into to
the cloud service,
and started
cryptocurrency mining.
So on GKE, we had actually
made this hardening change
before these attacks occurred.
In 1.8, GKE enabled role-based
access controller, RBAC,
by default in the V1 API.
RBAC is a method of
restricting access to resources
based on roles and permissions.
In Kubernetes, it's implemented
to allow you control access
to pods, deployments, config
maps, jobs, basically,
anything you can think of.
It's meant to replace
the prior authentication
method of attribute
based access control
and provides a more intuitive
way of handling permissions.
By using RBAC, you
can more easily
follow the principle of
least privileged to set rules
with minimum permissions to
resources inside your cluster.
In 1.8.3, GKE enabled Cloud
Audit Logging with the default
Kubernetes policy, so that both
your GCP API and the Kubernetes
API audit logs are
written to Stackdriver
for admin activities.
This is to easily go back
and see who did what and when
in your cluster.
In 1.10, in response to the
attacks that I mentioned
earlier that were happening
in the wild against Tesla
and others, we--
I just lost my mic.
OK, good.
In response to the attack,
which occurred in the wild,
against Tesla and others,
we disabled the Kubernetes
dashboard by default in GKE.
Instead, you can use
the Cloud Console
to have the same functionality
to monitor your clusters.
The next bit requires a
little bit of explanation.
So Kubernetes offers several
authentication methods.
In GKE, the supported methods
are OpenID connect tokens,
x509 client certificates,
and static passwords.
GKE manages
authentication for G Cloud
by using the OpenID
Connect Token method,
setting up the Kubernetes
configuration for you,
getting an access token,
and keeping it up to date.
The other
authentication methods,
x509 certs and static passwords,
present a wider surface
of attack.
So basic OS has never
really been a best practice.
And x509 certs in Kubernetes
are poorly auditable.
So unless your application
specifically needs these,
you shouldn't be enabling
these in your cluster.
So starting in 1.12,
GKE no longer generates
these credentials
for you by default,
when you create a new cluster.
And also in 1.12,
GKE removed access
to the GCE legacy metadata
server APIs for your cluster.
Some practical attacks
that were happening
in the wild against
Kubernetes rely
on access to the
VMs metadata server
to extract the
node's credentials.
Notably, Shopify, last
year, had a bug bounty,
where a researcher
accessed this metadata
and had broader access to
the cluster than expected.
So we removed that by default.
Note that all of these
hardening efforts that I've
been talking about change the
defaults for new clusters.
We can't do this
for older clusters
to allow for backwards
compatibility.
So if you have an older cluster
that you've been continually
upgrading, please go in
and make sure to change
some of these
defaults yourselves
to get the leading
edge security.
So critically,
though, Google is also
responsible for
patching anything
running in the control plane.
We have a high bar
for security, but bugs
do occur in open source
projects and things that
are running in your clusters.
So we want make sure to
properly patch these.
Google automatically
upgrades the master VMs,
but you're responsible
for upgrading your nodes.
And I'll talk more about auto
node upgrade in a second.
So since there are so many
different pieces here,
let's quickly go over what
this looks like in practice.
It depends where the
vulnerability is.
If the vulnerability is in the
kernel or an operating system,
Google will apply the patch
to affected components,
including obtaining
and applying the patch
to host images for
Kubernetes, COS, and Ubuntu.
Spectre, and Meltdown,
and L1 TF are examples
of such vulnerabilities.
If the vulnerabiliy
is in Kubernetes,
Google is involved in
Kubernetes' product security
team and often helps
develop and test patches
for Kubernetes vulnerabilities.
Since GKE is an
official distribution,
Google receives
the patch as part
of the private
distributors list.
If the vuln is in a component
used in GKE's default
configuration, for example,
Calico's container network
interface, CNI, or an
etcd, then in this case,
Google may receive a patch
from upstream Kubernetes
from a partner or from
the distributor list
of another open source project.
And lastly, if the
vuln is in GKE itself,
for example, if it's discovered
through Google Vulnerability
Rewards Program, then Google
is responsible for developing
and applying the fix.
In all of these cases,
Google makes the patches
available as part of general
Kubernetes Engine releases,
which are the patch releases and
bug fixes as soon as possible,
given the level of
risk, embargo time,
and any other
contextual factors.
Where the vulnerability
is severe enough or user
action is required, we
publish a security bulletin
detailing this information
on our website.
So that was the control plane.
Now, let's look at the
nodes-- the worker nodes.
For your nodes, Google
does most of the hard work
by providing the
components that you need
and the patches that
you need for those
when there's a security issue.
But it's still
your responsibility
to upgrade in order to
reap those benefits.
In Kubernetes, your
worker nodes are
where you run your workloads.
Your worker nodes in GKE consist
of a few different surfaces
that need to be
protected, including
the node OS, the container
runtime, Kubernetes
components like the
kubelet and kube-proxy,
and Google system containers
for monitoring and logging.
Google provides all
of these components
and, where necessary, you decide
what you want for your nodes.
So you get to choose the
operating system between COS
and Ubuntu, and you choose
a runtime that you'd like.
Separate containers run
for Kubernetes components,
like kube-proxy and
kube DNS, and Google
specific add-ons to provide
logging, monitoring,
and other services.
Google's responsible
for those containers.
In all of these cases, Google
is responsible for patching
these components, but you
are responsible for deciding
when to upgrade to
apply those patches.
So for example, a patch
to COS, to container D,
or Kubernetes would
all be provided by GKE,
but the user has to
upgrade to apply them.
Let's talk a little bit
more about the OS choice.
GKE provides two options
for your node OS.
Again, this is the OS
running on your node,
not the OS running
inside of your container.
You can use Container Optimized
OS, or COS, and Ubuntu.
As mentioned earlier, GKE's
control plane uses COS.
So you're deciding what you want
to run on your worker nodes.
So why should you consider COS?
Well, it has a couple of
nice security properties.
COS is based off of Chromium OS.
Google maintains all
of these components
as it is able to rebuild from
source if a new vulnerability
is discovered and
needs to be patched,
often allowing us to make
a patch available sooner
than if using a third
party distribution.
COS is minimal and has a
smaller attack surface.
COS is purpose built
to run containers
and so has a smaller
footprint than other OSes.
This means less code, less
complexity, and therefore
less patching.
There's less stuff
to patch if you never
had the component
in the first place.
COS is hardened with
good security defaults.
I really want to emphasize this.
This is very critical for some
of the recent vulnerabilities
we've had, like runC.
These were preventable because
of COS' security properties.
A firewall restricts all TCP UDP
traffic, except SSH on Port 22.
And load pin prevents kernel
modules from being installed.
A read only root file
system and verified boot
makes persistence for
attackers more difficult.
COS also allows security
features like Satcom
to further constrain
your application
to its normal behavior and
EVPF for third party security
products to monitor.
Lastly, COS offers
automatic updates.
So in GKE, we
provide COS updates
on a weekly basis as part of
the normal release process.
Your nodes will automatically
download the updates
in the background and then
upgrade when you reboot.
So we've been talking
about nodes and how
your primary responsibility for
these nodes, to protect them,
is to update them.
To make sure you benefit
from the hard work
that Google does, to patch the
pieces running on your nodes.
What if even that, you could
just hand over to Google?
And that's exactly what
node auto upgrade is.
It's funny.
I think we talk a lot
about node auto upgrade
as being a reliability feature,
but I entirely think about it
as being a security feature.
Node upgrades help
keep your nodes up
to date with the latest,
stable version of Kubernetes.
This means you stay up to
date with feature changes,
but it also means
that Google can
apply a security patch to
your nodes when it's critical.
Node auto upgrade
is available for COS
and also, more
recently, for Ubuntu.
So you have no reason
not to turn it on.
So I mentioned that node
auto upgrade keeps you
on the latest, stable patch.
How does this work if there's
a newly disclosed security
vulnerability?
Well, a patch with
a vulnerability fix
is rolled into the
first possible release
after public disclosure.
Often, this is the
patch that's released
the day of a disclosure,
but then takes
multiple days to actually
roll out and be available
everywhere.
Then several weeks later, once
a release is considered stable,
it's applied to the whole fleet.
For some security patches where
it's politically critical,
this is actually
done much sooner.
So why would you not
turn on auto grade?
Well, you might need deeper
validation of an update
yourself or want additional
control and predictability
for your SRE team to be on call.
If this is the case, consider
turning on auto upgrade
with a maintenance window,
so that it will only apply it
during that time period.
We also see users turn
off note auto upgrade
around major launches or
events like Black Friday,
where changes are particularly
sensitive to their environment.
Node auto upgrade works
by creating a new node
and moving the workload
over to that node.
Let me quickly
explain how surge auto
upgrade works, which
are newer developments
to node auto upgrade.
First, we create a new surge VM.
And once it's up and running,
create the node on that VM.
That takes a few minutes.
Once the new node is
ready, the old node
is drained of the workload.
And once it's fully
drained, the workload
resumes on the new node.
Draining the old node
takes a few seconds.
And with the workload up
and running on the new node,
we can now delete the old VM.
So we heard in the
keynote this morning,
talk about live migration.
This is applying the same
concept for your workloads,
for your nodes running
in your environment.
Live migration also
underlies all of GKE,
so you get that
automatically, anyways.
And because of the
security benefits and ease
of maintenance,
we're slowly moving
to making auto
upgrade the default
for new clusters in GKE.
So for clusters
created in the UI
since about October, auto
upgrade is checked by default.
For clusters created
with G Cloud,
starting for G
Cloud beta in 1.13,
you no longer have to pass
the enable auto upgrade
flag if you don't want to.
I'm sorry, to enable this.
If you don't want
to use this, you
can pass the dash dash no
enable auto upgrade flag.
And it's not yet the
default in the API, though.
So be careful if
you're an opt in,
if you're primarily
using the API.
In all of these
cases, though, you
can still opt out by unchecking
a box or passing a flag.
Great.
Let's talk about
workload security.
JESSE ENDAHL: So what we've
been talking about so far
is the underlying infrastructure
that runs your workloads.
But of course, you
still have to worry
about the workloads themselves,
and application security,
and other aspects
of your workloads.
Protecting that is your
responsibility, not Google's.
So when we talk about
hardening your workloads,
there's really two places you
need to look to secure them--
your Kubernetes configs that
pertain to your workloads
and, obviously, the
workloads themselves.
So last year, Maya and
I presented a roadmap
for securing your organization
on Kubernetes as it matures.
Some of the things are
handled automatically by GKE,
and some aren't.
Last year, specifically in
terms of Kubernetes configs,
we talked about a few of
these things, not all of them.
Things like using
a network policy,
using namespaces, and setting
a pod security policy.
And one that we didn't go
into in detail last year
is protecting secrets.
So we'll talk a little bit
more about that, today.
In terms of additional
controls you
can put in place for
your application,
you can verify
binaries, scan images
for known vulnerabilities,
and use sandboxing.
To learn more about
all this stuff,
check out that talk
from last year.
It's called Kubernetes
for enterprise security
requirements.
And for an up to date
list of best practices,
we recommend checking out
the "Hardening Your Cluster
Security" guide.
This year, we wanted
to focus on a few
of those areas we didn't
get to dive into last year,
like I mentioned, such
as protecting secrets.
So what is a secret?
A secret can be a lot
of different things.
Technically, it's
any sensitive data
that your application
needs either at
build time or runtime.
Some common examples are
TLS private keys, API keys,
username and
password combinations
to access your
database, for example,
or external services like
your payments processor,
such as a stripe API key.
Things that are not
considered secrets
are your code and general
configuration files.
So let's say you're using
Nginx as your web server.
The Nginx config
file is not a secret,
but the TLS private key that's
referenced by that config
is a secret.
It's also worth
calling out that there
is sensitive data or personally
identifiable information, PII.
These things are not considered
quote unquote "secrets,"
even though they're
obviously sensitive data.
And you still want to protect
that sensitive data or PII,
but generally, you
want to do that
by encrypting it before it's
written to the database,
for example.
And you wouldn't typically store
that type of sensitive data
directly inside your
secrets management system.
So by default in
Kubernetes, secrets
are stored in that
storage layer in etcd,
but they have no
additional protection.
They're protected in the
same way as the rest of etcd.
So a pod can access secrets
via the file system,
either as an environment
variable or via an API call.
And effectively, all nodes
can access all secrets,
and users with access to
etcd can exfiltrate secrets
in plaintext.
Starting in Kubernetes
1.7, Kubernetes
offers application
layer encryption
for differential
protection of secrets.
Using this feature,
your secrets are
encrypted with a
key that's specified
in the local etcd secret config.
But this option is
actually not recommended,
because it doesn't actually
improve your security.
If you think about
your threat model,
it's actually the same
exact threat model
as it was before, since the
critical data that an attacker
would access is being stored
in the same place as the key.
So it doesn't really help you.
Starting in Kubernetes 1.10,
Kubernetes offers something
called envelope encryption of
secrets using a KMS provider.
We're not going to go into
a lot of detail, here.
But a quick summary
of how it works
is that there are
two keys and then
the data that's actually
being encrypted.
So in this case, the data
being encrypted, obviously,
is the Kubernetes secrets
that are stored with an etcd.
Key number one is called the
key encryption key, or KEK.
The only purpose of that key
is to encrypt the second key.
The second key is called
the data encryption key.
And as you can probably
guess, its only purpose
is to encrypt the data.
For more details on how
all this stuff works,
check out the talk by Seth
Vargo and Alex Chernokovski
called "Securing
Kubernetes Secrets."
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: It's
worth pointing out
that on Google Cloud, we've
used this functionality that's
from Kubernetes
natively into GKE.
So we support this
with a feature
called application
layer secrets encryption
for GKE, which is in beta.
You can use a key in Cloud KMS
to encrypt the data encryption
key that encrypts
your secrets in GKE.
It addresses the
encryption requirements
that a lot of users
have for those secrets
and provides that
separation of duties
between who manages the
secrets in your clusters
and who manages keys.
JESSE ENDAHL: So at
Fleetsmith, we currently
use Hashicorp Vault
for secrets management.
This is because we
currently run what
I call a hybrid environment,
where some of our application
runs in VMs and some
runs in containers.
So because of that,
we rely on something
called the GCP authentication
plugin for Hashicorp Vault
to bootstrap secrets
onto new instances.
If you're also running that
kind of hybrid structure--
lost the mic.
Hello?
Testing.
So if you're also
running a hybrid type
of cloud infrastructure, where
you have both instances or VMs,
as well as Kubernetes pods
or collections of containers,
then Vault is actually a
great solution for that.
You do have that
challenge, though,
of how do you safely
bootstrap those secrets
onto new instances and pods.
And that's where things
really get tricky.
So to make sure you're safely
bootstrapping those secrets,
you want to use the GCP off
method for your VMs with Vault,
and you want to use the
Kubernetes off method
to bootstrap secrets onto
your pods with Kubernetes.
And of course,
regardless, you want
to be really careful with
your ACLs to make sure
that you're scoping the
access to your secrets
to only the pods or only the
VMs that actually need access
to those secrets.
I will actually say, though,
if you're starting fresh today,
and you don't have
legacy reasons
for rolling your own
Kubernetes cluster,
I highly recommend
just going with GKE
and using encrypted secrets.
If you want to learn
more info on that topic,
check out the talk,
"Key-less Entry.
Securely Accessing GCP
Services From Kubernetes."
That talk is tomorrow,
Wednesday, April 10th,
from 2:10 to 3:00 PM.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Awesome.
So other ways we can help
with your workload security,
Google offers a few products and
features to make this easier.
First, managed base images
and distroless images.
So I was talking earlier a
lot about the node image,
the node OS.
This is about what's running
inside your container.
You're going to have a
base image that you build
your container on top
of, and you build it
into an application image.
And that's actually
what you deploy.
So your container image is built
by taking that operating system
base image and
adding the libraries,
the packages, the binaries
that you actually need.
Managed based images
are one option.
These are images that
are patched for security
vulnerabilities
automatically by Google
with the most recently
available patches from upstream.
Google maintains
several base images
for building its
own applications,
including things
like App Engine.
So managed based images actually
have a couple of nice security
properties as well
that make them
a desirable choice
for your applications.
Specifically, they're
regularly scanned
for known vulnerabilities
from the CVE database.
This scanning is done using
the same functionality
as Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning,
if you've seen that before.
And where a patch for
these exists, it's applied.
They're built reproducibly, so
that there is a verifiable path
from source code to the binary.
That means that the
image can be verified
to ensure that no flaws have
been introduced by comparing it
to source.
And lastly, they're
stored on Google Cloud,
so you can pull them directly
from your environment
without having to
traverse networks.
You can pull these images
using private Google access.
Managed base images are
available for Debian, Ubuntu,
and CentOS.
Another option, an
alternative to managed based
images are distroless images.
These images only
contain your application
and it's runtime
dependencies, greatly reducing
the potential surface of attack.
A package with a newly
discovered vulnerability
can't affect you if
you don't actually have
the package in the first place.
This is how you become
more secure, less stuff.
Distroless images remove
package managers, shells,
or other programs that you
might find in a standard Linux
distribution, so that you're
focusing on what's actually
important, which is dealing
with the vulnerability
scan results that you
have and leaving you
with less to maintain.
Distroless images are language
focused and available for many
languages, including Java,
Python, Node.js, .NET,
and more, as well as a static
image for statically compiled
languages like Go, Rest, and D.
Both distroless
images and managed
based images are good
choices for your containers.
It really depends on what
works in your environment.
If you need a full Linux
distribution, including
features like a package
manager or a shell,
then managed based
images are a good choice.
If you want the most
locked down option
possible, then distroless
images might be better for you.
So now that you
have a base image
and you've actually built
your container image,
you have something that you're
storing in your image registry
that you're going to deploy.
So for those application
images, you'll
also want to avoid including any
known vulnerabilities in those.
To assess that in Google
Container Registry,
you can use
vulnerability scanning.
GCR vulnerability
scanning, when enabled,
scans all the images in your
private registry for known CVEs
from the CVE database.
This is displayed
in your registry
with info as to whether
a fix is available
and the severity of the
vulnerability, et cetera,
so that you can
actually take action.
This scan is conducted
on a new image when
it's added to the registry, as
well as, for existing images,
when a new vulnerability
is discovered and added
to the database.
GCR vulnerability scanning is
available for Debian, Ubuntu,
CentOS, and Alpine images.
And at the end of the day, if
you're responding to something
happening in your
environment, you
can look up at Cloud
Security Scanner.
Sorry, that made no sense.
You can also use Cloud Security
Scanner to scan for common web
application vulnerabilities.
Like for other services,
security scanner
can be used on public facing
applications hosted on GKE.
It scans for cross-eyed
scripting, mixed content,
outdated libraries, clear text
passwords, and other common,
like OS top 10 like vulns.
So now, we've protected our
infrastructure-- the control
plane, the worker nodes, and
your workloads themselves.
And unfortunately, in security,
bad things still happen.
So what do you do when you
have to respond to a security
incident?
Now, it's also worth noting
I'm making a difference here
between incidents
and vulnerabilities.
A new vulnerability,
if it's not currently
being exploited in
your environment,
is not an incident.
You should have that handled
by your normal vulnerability
assessment response team.
So responding to attacks
on Google's infrastructure
is Google's responsibility,
whereas responding
to attacks on user workloads
is the user's responsibility.
Basically, we're each
responsible for responding
to attacks on pieces
that we protect.
That makes sense.
So how do you handle
incident response?
JESSE ENDAHL: So before
we answer that question,
we have to define what
does that actually mean,
being responsible for incident
response on your workloads.
Well, it really
means, to start, you
need to understand the
incident response lifecycle.
And so let's just quickly
go over those stages.
That means being
able to identify when
an incident actually occurs.
Establishing a runbook
for what happens
once an incident is declared.
Staffing your own
response team, who
will actually be
following that runbook
in the case of an incident.
Understanding the
scope of the incident
by conducting forensics.
And finally, notifying
any affected users,
if that's applicable, and
developing and executing
on a remediation plan.
So if you're responding
to an incident,
and you're on Google
Cloud, there's
a few tools that you
can leverage with GKE
to help conduct your
own incident response.
First up is absolutely critical.
You need to make sure you have
a centralized log aggregation
system set up.
On Google Cloud, Stackdriver
could help with this.
It comes prepackaged
with common queries that
are helpful for
addressing incidents,
specifically, that occur on GKE.
So for example, in the case
of a cluster compromise,
you might want to quickly
check what resources
were accessed by the attacker.
And you can leverage those types
of built in queries instead
of spending valuable minutes
on writing those queries
from scratch yourself.
And next, Stackdriver Incident
Response and Management
is a new product from Google.
That's in alpha.
It's a set of new tooling
that they're specifically
developing to help
you reduce time
to mitigation in an
incident response
scenario on Google Cloud.
If you're interested in more
material on incident response,
including how Google
themselves uses
a really awesome open
source tool called Gur,
internally, I highly recommend
a talk from last year's Google
Cloud Next called,
"Cloud Forensics 101."
And if you're a
startup that's just
getting started with
incident response,
there's a really
great starting point
in the form of a blog post by
someone named Brian McKehan.
It's titled, "An Incident
Response Plan For Startups,"
and you can find the link
at the end of this talk.
Finally, I do want to call out--
Brian's not a Googler.
He's formally a director of
incident response at Facebook,
as well as director of
security at CoinBase.
And he currently has
his own consulting firm
called R10N Security.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So
if you are responding
to an incident on GCP,
then you probably want
to [INAUDIBLE] at the Cloud
Security Command Center, first.
Cloud Security Command
Center is the single pane
of glass for security
events in your environment.
For scans that you run
in your environment,
you can the results that apply.
There are GKE clusters here.
As you're looking to
further protect yourself
from potential container
specific attacks,
Google Cloud already has a range
of container security partners
integrated with Cloud CSCC.
These look for attacks against
your container workloads
and then alert you
directly, natively in CSCC.
These include Aqua Security,
Capsule8, StackRox,
Sysdig Secure, and
Twistlock, and we're always
looking to add more to
our partner offering.
So we've talked a lot about a
handful of security features
that you can leverage in Google
Kubernetes Engine and Google
Cloud, but there's
actually lots more.
GKE also offers features
like private clusters
and pod security policy to help
you protect your workloads.
Another one that I
didn't talk about,
which I want to
quickly emphasize,
is binary authorization,
which is inspired
by what Google does
internally to verify code
before it's deployed.
So you can actually
use that to enforce
what gets put into
your environment
based on an attestation.
So for example, to enforce
that, code must come out of your
build pipeline, or it must be
scanned by your vulnerability
scanner.
Using these pieces together
leads to a stronger security
posture, because after all,
strong security is really
about defense in depth.
So putting it all
together, let's answer
that initial question
of who protects what.
In GKE, Google is responsible
for protecting the control
plane, which includes
your master VM, etcd,
and controllers.
And you're responsible for
protecting your worker nodes,
including deploying patches to
the OS, runtime, and Kubernetes
components, and of course,
securing your own workload.
So what could you
do today to start
securing Kubernetes on GKE?
We'd recommend that you stay
at the forefront of security
by using node auto upgrade,
protecting your workload
from common image
and application
vulnerabilities
using managed base
images or distroless images,
and GCR Vuln Scanning,
and following the
"Kubernetes Engine Hardening
Guide" to get on the latest
set of configurations
that we'd recommend.
And when you have
a bit more time,
check out some of the additional
content that we covered
and additional
documents we link to.
So here is a set of
links to learn more.
The first one is a
blog post that covers
the content of today's talk.
There's a landing page
on container security,
a link to an overview on
security, the hardening guide,
and the security bulletins.
That's what I mentioned earlier.
When there's a new
vulnerability disclosed,
that's where we
post information.
It has an RSS feed.
You can use that to post
directly to your team's Slack
channel, for example.
And then the last
two points there
are incident response white
paper and our infrastructure
security design white paper.
And if you're at Next
the rest of this week,
check out some of
the other talks
on container security going on.
So we're in the
upper left, here.
But there's a talk
later today on secrets
and on networking, and then
tomorrow on securely accessing
GCP services from Kubernetes.
Thursday, on software supply
chain, policy management,
and gVisor.
That's it for us.
Thank you so much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]